ganz andere frage wer hat alles bot mal
wieder über den berg sind zu reden ja
wird verschoben
verbreitet wird verschoben auf den
auf den 22
dass man euch mit sonder sachen so viel
freude machen kann das ist also auf den
22 mai oder auf den zwölften april wird
die engländer irgendwas nicht machen
keine ahnung ich habe nicht mehr
zugehört ja man kann es nicht mehr
der brh exit steckt fest in der mutter
aller sackgassen und europa hat so
langsam die faxen dicke der brh exit
nervt die spinnen die briten
großbritannien muss jetzt langsam die
kurve kratzen doch die franzosen zb an
den hals jetzt dicke nase voll die nase
voll die nase gestrichen voll von den
briten
[Applaus]
es ist ja so sie werfen die st diese
brächten sie nerven wie sau
entschuldigung bei allem respekt rexit
wann darf die eu sich endlich wieder mit
irgendwas anderen beschäftigt mit
irgendwas ich guck im fernsehen
mittlerweile schon dokus über das
reizdarmsyndrom nur mal was schönes zu
sehen
ja und die engländer selber können es ja
auch nicht mehr hören
wir haben abgestimmt die mehrheit hat
für raus gestimmt und jetzt all das nie
so dauert das so lange schon hat völlig
recht mehr damen und herren völlig recht
nach meinem kalender ist heute in einer
woche praxis feierabend heute in einer
woche
ich hatte mir schon einen ganzen kasten
englisches bier gekauft wollte ich zur
feier des tages dann wegschmeißen und
jetzt schlimm und theresa may politisch
erledigt ist jetzt endgültig in der
trotzphase angekommen sieht man auch an
ihren merkwürdigen abgängen sie sagt
jetzt am ende ihrer bizarren reden nicht
mal mehr tschüss
aber jetzt sollen sie und will das volk
dass wir den herbeiführen am titel nimmt
und elchen bin entschlossen das zu tun
was die wand völlig von der rolle
völlig von der rolle nächsten dienstag
hat sie wohl ihre letzte chance im
unterhaus wie es aussieht wobei man er
ja eigentlich verboten hat wissen sie
immer wieder denselben deal da
einzubringen
auf grund eines gesetzes von 1604 was
beweist dass ist vor 400 jahren mal
kluge engländer gab meine damen und
herren
und selbst in der eigenen partei hat die
mir ein echtes imageproblem
luisa mails problem ist einfach dass sie
nur ein einziges programm abspulen kann
fast wie ein defekter roboter dass sie
von allen tory parteimitgliedern gehasst
wird weil sie keine empathie habe weil
sie nicht zuhöre sie sei zitat so etwas
wie das schwarze loch der britischen
politik
wow das hört jeder gern charmant so
wichtig ist jetzt nur eins dass diese
engländer in keinem fall doch noch an
der europawahl im mai teilnehmen das
wäre ein alptraum
wirklich welche handverlesenen idioten
schicken sie dann wieder nach brüssel
zum bremsen wahrscheinlich die beiden
trawlers die damals wissen sie noch
diesen schrecklichen braig sitzung
gesungen haben
[Musik]
china
damit kommt
ja sie merken es selbst mit den spice
girls geht's bergab in diesem tag war
hauptsache die anderen 27 eu länder
halten jetzt zusammen als
wertegemeinschaft damit die populisten
nicht abräumen bei der europawahl darum
geht er hier in der mitte zb viktor
orban sollte eigentlich am mittwoch aus
der so genannten e vp dem
zusammenschluss der konservativen
europäer rausfliegen und zwar weil er
ein
hier wie heißt das noch was der mann von
beruf ist
[Applaus]
ja
so begrüßt mich meine familie jeden
abend also der ungar orban sollte
rausfliegen aus der svp aber dann hieß
es diese woche pustekuchen
seine seine mitgliedschaft ruht jetzt
für ein paar monate sie ruht nur damit
manfred weber von der csu bei der wahl
zum nächsten kommissionspräsidenten
nicht die stimmen der orban partei
verliert der mann der orban hat gerade
wieder zitat starke führer für europa
gefordert und das hier plakatiert in
ungarn juncker +1 lieblingsfeind soros
mittlerweile ja das synonym für juden
die in den wahnvorstellungen der rechten
die welt kontrollieren das ist
lupenreiner antisemitismus wie aus dem
stürmer ausgeschnitten plus dreiste
lügen über die eu dabei könnte organs
korrupte regierung gar nicht überleben
keine minute überleben ohne kohle aus
europa dafür könnte uns schon mal den
einen oder anderen flüchtlinge abnehmen
finde ich der beste einwanderer ist der
der gar nicht kommt die beste zahl ist 0
wir wollen nicht mit anderen zusammen
leben sondern unter uns bleiben macht er
ja auch unter euch bleiben
ich sage mal wenn er jetzt noch lernt
ohne ausländisches geld auszukommen wäre
es perfekt wieso haben sie den nicht
rausgeschmissen aus der vp ich kann
ihnen sagen weil sie chips haben dass er
sich sonst den rechten anschließt oder
der polnischen pis partei
der aus polen ja die heißt also
entschuldigung leute bitte
so entscheidung aus dieser woche jetzt
soll ein sogenannter rat der weisen in
den nächsten monaten ich zitiere
evaluieren ob orban und seine partei
noch zu den werten der konservativen
passen was bitter aber ich mich gefragt
ist ein rat der weisen und vor allem das
will ich auch haben der heute show
weisenrat in gestelltes weisen christian
ehring evaluiert viktor orban
weiser ehring ich frage dich wird ungarn
unter orban noch mal zu einer richtigen
demokratie nein
tja dann sag ich mal danke sagen
ein moment ich habe ja noch gar nicht zu
ende evaluiert natürlich ist ungarn seit
jahren kein richtiger rechtsstaat mehr
und sicher ob man hetzt in ekelhafter
weise gegen flüchtlinge und muslime
trotzdem muss man ihm ja mal zu hören
er kann seine politik zu ändern und wenn
die politik werde ich nicht stehen dann
ja wie gesagt danke weiß eric hinsetzen
hinsetzen und weise so einfach ist es
nicht klar könnte man aus der vp
rausschmeißen oder sogar aus der eu
wegen westliche werte bla bla bla bla
aber das wäre nicht weise dagegen
sprechen nämlich drei ganz entscheidende
argumente mercedes bmw und audi
das sind autos sehr gut richtig nimm den
keks alle drei konzerne haben riesige
werke in ungarn und genießen mit die
niedrigsten unternehmenssteuern europas
die ungarischen löhne liegen im schnitt
bei 700 euro netto und dann vor ein paar
wochen hat der große führer auch noch
ein geniales neues gesetz eingeführt
es erlaubt arbeitgebern zukünftig bis zu
400 überstunden im jahr anzuordnen und
deren bezahlungen bis zu drei jahre
hinauszuzögern
so geht populismus die doofen gehen auf
die straße und rufen wir wollen keine
arbeitsmigranten und die regierung sagt
gute idee dann arbeitet ihr halt 400
stunden mehr
in vielen betrieben gibt es wieder eine
sechs-tage-woche wie weise ist das nicht
ach so
bmw und audi natürlich deswegen hat die
csu den ordnern immer so folge schleim
na ja klar das war ja ein run gewarnt so
dass man jene gilt es ging ja schon fast
in den bereich sexuelle nötigung
[Musik]
sie sagen es ihnen aus dem soft porno
bayern hat von rechts genommen
so meine prognose orban bleibt in der
evb schade aber weiße ring wo ich gerade
hier bin kurze frage zum rexit gibt es
da den wenigstens noch ein happy end
nein weil theresa may in dieser woche
leider offiziell verrückt geworden ist
sie beschimpft inzwischen ihr eigenes
parlament geht im bademantel auf die
straße und trägt dazu auf dem kopf ein
explodiertes meerschweinchen
für weitere videos klickt unten und
abonniert auch unseren channel alles im
kasten
ok
[Musik]
wo geht's denn hier raus
scheiße